schauen wir doch mal rein welchen ihr
sinn robert habeck gestern abend in der
sendung von sandra maischberger erzählt
hat das sehen wir jetzt überall das
leben die darauf angewiesen sind dass
die menschen geld ausgeben blumenläden
bioläden leckereien gehören dazu dass
die wirkliche probleme haben weil ist
eine kaufzurückhaltung gibt und dann
sind die nicht insolvent automatisch
aber sie hören vielleicht auf zu
verkaufen und du hast nicht aufhöre zu
verkaufen und verdiene ich kein geld
mehr da muss ich die insolvenz anmelden
nach zwei monaten wenn dies nicht getan
habe habe ich in so würde man würde dann
insolvent werden wenn man mit der arbeit
immer größeres minus macht ja aber wie
würde denn kein größeres minus machen
wenn sie leute bezahlen aber dies wir
verkaufen also
wie soll man also ich hab es nicht
verstehe ich weiß doch automatisch eine
insolvenzwelle geben geben muss aber es
kann sein dass ich bestimmte geschäfte
nicht mehr rentieren und hier dann
eingestellt werden vielleicht werden sie
spielt er wieder aufgenommen das kann ja
sein also das ist dann ja keine
klassische insolvenz aber es kann sein
wenn wir keine abhilfe schaffen dass die
betriebe dakar ein handwerksbetriebe
reinigungsfirmen und so weiter über
dieses jahr dann die wirtschaftliche
betätigung einstellen das ist eine
gefahr und der müssen wir begegnen frau
wagenknecht so erklärt robert habeck
eine insolvenz beziehungsweise eine
nicht insolvenz man merkt auf jeden fall
braucht nachhilfe vertrauen sie diese
minister dennoch also ich meine den
kammern ja nicht vertrauen ich muss
sagen als ich das gesehen habe ich war
einfach fassungslos
also ich wir haben wir befinden uns in
einer dramatischen situation
deutschland steuert wegen dieser
explodierenden energiepreise auf eine
wirtschaftliche und soziale katastrophe
zu und wir haben im
wirtschaftsministerium jemanden sitzen
der offenbar elementare wirtschaftliche
zusammenhänge nicht kennt oder nicht
durchschaut oder nicht durchschauen will
und ich mein ok man kann ja mal einen
ausfall haben man kann mal einen abend
schlecht drauf sein also das könnte man
ja noch hinnehmen aber ehrlich gesagt
das ist ja nicht der erste ausfall ich
mein während andere länder zum beispiel
energiepreise deckeln in frankreich
steigt steigt der strompreis in diesem
jahr um vier prozent im ganzen jahr der
sprit diesel und benzin sind um 14 cent
pro liter billiger als hier und während
also hier alles weiter nach oben geht
hat unser toller wirtschaftsminister die
idee das mache ich noch mal ein bisschen
was oben drauf machen gas umlage und
lässt auch noch die energie lobbyisten
diese gasanlage also das gesetz dafür
schreiben und wundert sich dann dass es
genauso aussieht wie es aussieht wenn
hobbyisten von unternehmen sich ein
gesetz basteln nämlich ein
selbstbedienungsladen also insoweit das
ist ja eine folge von ausfällen und ich
sag mal wenn nur ein minister schlecht
drauf wäre in dieser ampel wohl das ist
ja ein schlüssel ressort aber auch das
wäre schon schlimm genug aber es ist ja
die ganze regierung ich meine die haben
den ernst der lage nicht erkannt sie
haben uns nochmal da ein neues
entlastungspaket offeriert klopfen sich
auf die schulter wie viel sie da jetzt
machen natürlich sind da auch sinnvolle
dinge drin also das will ich hier abrede
stellen also nachdem man die rentner und
die studenten vergessen hatte ist es
natürlich gut dass die jetzt auch
einmalzahlung bekommen und es ist sicher
auch gut dass wohngeldempfänger jetzt
einen heizkostenzuschuss bekommen wobei
man eben auch wissen muss
98,5 prozent der deutschen bevölkerung
sind keine wohngeldempfänger und auch
bei denen explodieren die heizkosten und
was noch viel schlimmer ist und das ist
ja wieder das thema auch was hab ich ja
so versucht kleinzureden die
insolvenzwelle hat ja schon begonnen die
insolvenzen steigen und das obwohl die
richtige kostenlawine viele unternehmen
erst im nächsten jahr treffen wird weil
sie langfristige verträge haben für
energielieferungen wir haben einen
deutlichen
produktionseinbruch also es wird ja
immer so gesagt die industrie verbraucht
wird sich 20 prozent weniger gas da sagt
die regierung teilweise noch eine gute
leistung ja woran liegt denn das das
liegt daran dass die produktion
dramatisch zurückgeht aluminiumhütten
porzellanhersteller
papierindustrie in so vielen bereichen
sind inzwischen schon werden produktion
eingestellt wir haben verlagerungen
beispielsweise in die usa weil der
gaspreis in deutschland seit acht mal so
hoch ist wie in den usa da kündigen
viele an ja wir gehen dahin und deswegen
finde ich einfach wir müssen doch über
die wirklichen ursachen mal reden wir
können es uns in deutschland nicht
leisten dass unsere energie immer teurer
wird wir brauchen preiswerte energie und
wir können die aktuell das gefällt mir
auch nicht ich finde dass wie schön aber
wie können sie aktuell nur in russland
beziehen deswegen muss man ganz klar
sagen schluss mit diesen fatalen
wirtschaftssanktionen die schaden uns
gazprom macht rekordgewinne haben dieses
jahr schon im ersten halbjahr mehr
verdient als im ganzen jahr zuvor ja
also wie kann man den glauben dass wir
damit putin bestrafen bestrafen uns wir
stürzen die menschen in armut wir
zerstören unsere industrie und ich finde
das darf man so nicht weitermachen und
das muss doch eigentlich ist aufgabe der
ampel verhandeln sie über eine
wiederaufnahme der gaslieferungen heben
sie da die sanktionen auch weil sonst
zerstören wir wirklich deutschland und
die welle das kann man nicht die
deutsche wirtschaft aber eben auch den
wohlstand der menschen und dass es
inakzeptabel denn es würden sie mitgehen
ich finde es ist ungeheuer wichtig dass
deutschland sich besser schützen kann
auch in dem es nicht abhängig ist vom
russischen gas jetzt es stimmt auch dass
deutschland weiter russischen gas chaos
bis 91 jetzt geschlossen worden ist weil
wir wissen ja alle dass so eine schnelle
veränderung auf andere energiequellen
unheimliche nicht nur wirtschaft in
unseren sozialen kosten hat nicht
möglich ist
also ich bin zuversichtlich aus manchen
dass ein markt ziemlich schnell
reagieren kann
aber man muss auch bereit sein zu sagen
jetzt ist opfer verlag denn man hat so
lange federn gemacht wenn man den
atommeilern ausschalten will okay aber
dann muss man ein alternativ haben
sodass man krisen aus baden kann
länger in deutschland nicht anzapfen
will der kunde muss sagte wenn
deutschland hier schiefergas
anzapfen würde könnte es ein
gasproduktion in zwölf bis 18 monate
verdoppeln und 15 milliarden euro
bleiben in deutschland start nach
russland zu geben in dem sinne wir sehen
viele stellen wo nicht langfristig
gedacht worden ist und jetzt muss man
das ausbaden wenn man russland
wirtschaftssanktionen
aber ich bin für die
wirtschaftssanktionen war so viel auf
dem spiel steht ich will kein atom krieg
mit russland
ich will deutschlands wirtschaft auch
nicht ruiniert denn ich weiß wenn die
wirtschaft kaputt ist wie deutschland
sowieso nicht gegen russland aber ich
weiß auch
wenn putin der meinung ist dass
militärische operation gegen andere
länder in politische vorteile bringen da
wird immer wieder angreifen bringen die
wirtschaftssanktionen bislang also
wirtschaftlich zum beispiel natürlich
das volk kann nicht sofort aufstehen und
sagen wir wollen diesen krieg nicht mehr
landen die allem knast aber zb die
militärischen fähigkeiten russland sind
dramatisch gefallen war sie importen
nicht bekommen russland kauft
artilleriegeschosse von nordkorea das
haben die wirtschaftssanktionen gemacht
langfristig ist es auch so dass diese
fehlende gelder zugang zu westlichen
märkten den russen schaden wird aber
wegen wirtschaftsprobleme beenden das
glaube ich nicht aber die gute alte
lennon hat gesagt die kapitalisten die
werden uns dem saal verkaufen mit denen
wir die aufhängen und ich fürchte wir
haben zu lange die russen das geld
gegeben so dass sie andere länder
angreifen können und es gibt keinen
frieden in europa solange putin und
seine armee in ukraine militärisch aber
haben sie dennoch ein fakt wo sie sagen
da sieht man wirklich das hält da helfen
die wirtschaftssanktionen und
da sind detaillierte studien gemacht und
man hat ziemlich heber kraft aus
russland ist sehr von hightech abhängig
nicht nur in der waffenindustrie aber
die präzision waffen die die nicht mehr
haben die kunden nicht nach produzieren
auch in der energie forderung geht es
kaputt es ist schwierig für die russen
alle pumpen am laufen zu halten die
brauchen diese westliche technologie
jetzt langfristig vielleicht kann china
da reinkommen aber erst mal sind die
pipelines nach westen berichtet und wenn
diese gelten nicht mehr da sind und die
technologie nicht mehr da sind dann
werden die russen wenn es sich geld
übrig haben um ihre kriege sind
finanziert das leid ich meine
militärisch muss man denn auch vor
harten fakten stellen ich glaube dass
sanktionen allein nicht reichen wer aber
mal soll die trotzdem nicht aus und
geben machen einmal die runde weiter
frau kaufmann wenn sie die ganzen
probleme jetzt auch hier hören trauen
sie ist denn wirtschaftsminister harbeck
zu dass er richtig entscheidet
sanktionen notwendig oder nicht und den
kurs für deutschland kennt also
grundsätzlich traue ich das schon dem
wirtschaftsminister habe natürliches
gestern wieder ein beispiel was gerade
nicht gut läuft und ich merke dass als
bürgermeisterin auch sehr stark dass die
leute bei mir eine sprechende sitzen und
sagen was machen die da also die reden
auch schon von die da oben und das finde
ich ja auch schon sehr fatal wenn man
sich schon so in zwei schichten sieht
und gar nicht als 1 sieht so und wir
hatten jetzt das thema gas umlage was
leider
kommunikativ nicht sehr gut warum nicht
sehr stark weil es hatten wir gestern
wieder am beispiel das ist nicht das was
wir uns da ich meine basis wünschen also
wir wünschen uns klare direkte
kommunikation ist auch das was sich die
menschen vor ort wünschen die komme
damit klar wenn man den sagt das geht
oder das geht nicht es muss klar direkt
und schnell sein und nicht in einer
blase umwelt sein ich habe mal eine
grafik vorbereitet jetzt bild gefragt
also wir haben ja gesagt die da oben und
die bürger also wer traut ist denn
robert habeck eigentlich noch zu und da
sehen wir ja also das nur sieben prozent
glauben das habe ich uns durch die krise
bringt stand 17 35 93 prozent glauben es
nicht es waren jetzt auch gar nicht so
wenig teilnehmer sahen 290.000
dementsprechend die frage jetzt an ralf
schuler wie kann es denn sein nehmen wir
noch mal den auftritt von frau
maischberger gestern arbeiten denn im
wirtschaftsministerium keine fähigen
leute die ihn briefen können und
vielleicht auch vor diesem jahr debakel
bewahren können dass wir jetzt schon
wieder sehr beim eingemachte das
wirtschaftsministerium ist in einem
ständigen das ist traditionell so
machtkampf mit dem finanzministerium
oskar lafontaine damals als
finanzminister wurde hat als erstes dem
wirtschaftsministerium die
grundsatzabteilung weggenommen weil da
die experten darin saßen seitdem ist die
meines wissens bei finanzministerium
geblieben
da ist im augenblick jetzt das
wirtschaftsministerium in einer sehr
schlechten verfassung da ist wenig
wirtschaftskompetenz dafür hat robert
habeck als 1 amt kam sehr viele
klima-aktivisten und lobbyisten direkt
rheingold patrick reichen vorher agora
energiewende in ein lupenreiner lobbyist
der frühere grünen geschäftsführer
keller ist da jetzt staatssekretär die
haben alle mit wirtschaften nunmehr
mittelbares verhältnis weil man dachte
man muss das klima retten und nicht sich
um die wirtschaft kümmern dieses jahr da
und brummte das arbeit man das
wirtschaftsministerium ist jetzt auch
nicht die schülerhilfe für robbi tobbi
und das fliewatüüt das noch mal eben
auch ganz klar sagen wenn jemand ein
wirtschaftsminister ist insolvenz kann
man wissen das ist jetzt wirklich nicht
das ganze die ganz hohe kunst das
problem ist aber dass diese dieser
lapsus von
nicht berbalk das ist die andere von
erlaubten robert habe
symptomatisch ist denn frau habe frau
roth hat schon angesprochen diese gas
umlage ist ein massives politikversagen
einer der größten fehler das merkt man
nicht so richtig weil es ja technisch
daherkommt weil denen sich diese ampel
der zeit geleistet hat man hat einfach
uniqa mit uniqa besprochen haben gesagt
wir brauchen mehr geld wir können uns
aber nicht an unsere anteilseigner ist
würde seine finnische konzern kann man
es nicht wenden weil nahe das ist immer
schwierig einen anteilseigner hat ein
hohes interesse dass seine firma bleibt
und dass nicht so viel geld verliert die
stecken da schon geld rein und wenn man
dann hilft dann kauft man gefälligst
anteile und hat dann kann dann mit real
oder vor allem gegen los und und und
nicht 34 milliarden von den menschen
draußen ein um eine firma zu retten das
wäre billiger gegangen und es wäre auch
nicht zu solchen fehlleistungen gekommen
dass jetzt firmen dies überhaupt nicht
brauchen geld kriegen das ist völlig
irre und es ist ein zeichen dafür dass
sie nicht dass ich es nicht können das
ist einfach man hätte irgendein
wirtschaftsfachmann der sich mit
unternehmensrecht auskennt dazu holen
müssen dann hätte dann lösen wir das
problem nein das funktioniert nicht und
das ist leider eben eine fehlleistung
die beim kopf des ministeriums anfängt
und bis in die tiefen mit hinein geht
das ist auf die dauer wir haben das
nicht hinkriegen wenn jemand dort sitzt
der die anrollende pleitewelle mit einer
art betriebsferien verwechselt dann gute
nacht deutschland frau wagenknecht
gerade kam es auch schon auch frau
berbalk zu sprechen kann man denn
überhaupt sich vorstellen dass mit ihr
als außenministerin jemals die
wirtschaftssanktionen zurückgenommen
oder überhaupt überlegt wird sie zu zu
nehmen na ja gut das entscheidet nicht
die außenministerin am ende muss es
eigentlich in der gesamten regierung
entschieden werden und die frage ist ja
also das verstehe ich nicht man muss
doch mal eine bilanz ziehen also man hat
gesagt wir machen jetzt
wirtschaftssanktionen und putin unter
druck zu setzen ok also ich meine ich
will auch dass dieser furchtbaren krieg
aufhört und ich finde das auch
verbrecherisch wobei schon ein bisschen
fragwürdig finde auf andere kriege haben
wir nicht so reagiert mit sanktionen
also wenn saudi arabien irgendwo krieg
führt wenn der türkei oder gar die usa
gab es nie sagen aber egal also man hat
gesagt wir wollen jetzt putin unter
druck setzen so da muss man doch nach
mehreren monaten mal gucken wer setzt
jetzt eigentlich wenig unter druck ist
putin unter druck also dass sie jetzt
militärgüter brauchen ja klar weil die
führen jetzt krieg seit mehreren monaten
und so viel können die gar nicht
produzieren natürlich kaufen jetzt
weltweit ein aber am ende gucke ich mir
einfach an wie steht der rubel wir
stehen die russischen einnahmen die die
prosperieren sie hatten vor allem ja
auch erreicht der größte teil der welt
beteiligt sich nicht das öl ich meine
warum ist der ölpreis nicht so gestiegen
wie der gaspreis deshalb weil sie das öl
relativ leicht umlenken konnten also
jetzt kaufen eben china und indien alle
kaufen das öl teilweise kaufen wir es
sogar wieder indirekt weil indien
raffiniert also rafft macht raffinerien
mit russischem öl und verkauft uns dann
den diesel total brillante idee und weil
das so toll ist machen wir jetzt ende
des jahres das haben wir hat ja hab ich
auch entschieden klemmen wir jetzt noch
die letzte pipeline ab wo wir aus
russland öl bekommen dann raffiniert
nicht mehr schwedt sondern nur noch
indien und wir kaufen den diesel dann
dort zum fünffachen preis also völlig
verrückt und man muss doch jetzt einfach
sehen bei uns ist ein unglaublicher
schaden wir überleben das wirtschaftlich
nicht die deutsche industrie der der
wichtigste standort vorteil den wir
hatten war billige energie deswegen ist
deutschland nicht so deindustrialisiert
wie ein paar länder ich meine man kann
sich in nordengland angucken wie das
aussieht wenn die industrialisierung
stattfindet oder im raesfeld in den usa
das kennen sie wahrscheinlich besser als
ich dass sie dramatische
energie ist billig geworden in den usa
das ist ja auch interessant
jetzt ist es ja so es leiden ja auch
nicht alle gleich unter den sanktionen
ich meine da erwarte ich auch dass die
deutsche regierung mal bilanz zieht was
heißt das für unser land in den usa
bedeutet das eine boomende fracking
gasindustrie die jetzt ja auch
exportieren kann die also mit einem
tanker zurzeit 200 millionen euro gewinn
macht das seien dann alles hier die
verbraucher und die unternehmen oder sie
gehen im pleite so das heißt für die usa
ist das gar nicht so ein schlechtes
setting amerika nach deutschland
aufgerufen wohin ziehen und zu sein und
wir leiden und hier gehen die
unternehmen kaputt und ich meine wie
soll deutschland aussehen der der
dihk-präsident sagt wir werden
wahrscheinlich 20 bis 30 prozent ärmer
wenn wir das weiter machen 30 prozent
also frage ich mich dann in deutschland
sich so erpressbar gemacht hat aber es
ist auch verantwortungslos den russen
mehr geld zu geben als absolut notwendig
natürlich langfristig würde ich auch der
nordstream 2 wieder aufmachen aber nur
unter bestimmten bedingungen dass
russland seine truppen aus geräten
starten raus muss man mit denen
verhandeln ich bin ja
krieg zu beenden mit verhandlungen die
aber zunächst mal wissen wir doch gucken
russland hat durch die gestiegenen
preise obwohl sie viel weniger verkaufen
zum beispiel beim gas beim öl gar nicht
beim öl verkaufen sie fast genauso viel
haben sie rekordgewinne dh deutschland
hat im ersten halbjahr dieses jahres in
der monetär also geld mehr ist ich mehr
aus russland importiert als
sie sagen es würde länger dauern bis die
sanktionen wirken also der feuer das
halte ich jetzt für eine völlige legende
weil was passiert jetzt gasproben nutzt
die rekordgewinne und baut die pipelines
nach china aus das heißt baut
zusätzliche pipelines nach china
russland orientiert sich jetzt immer
stärker nach china ist ja auch logisch
können sie ja gar nicht anders und beim
öl ist es ohnehin schon so wollen wir
das wollen wir tatsächlich
dass russland in china oft mehr
miteinander zeigen als mit den anderen
nachbarn
herr lang habe der der fundamentale
punkt ist will deutschland weitet diese
krieg finanzieren und
dank sagen dass je weniger geld
deutschland nach russland schickt desto
besser jetzt sie haben auch recht wegen
öl breite heutzutage kann rösler
ziemlich viel noch einziehen aber nicht
von deutschland erstmal
antwort muss ist und wichtiger noch ist
dass putin sehr gut weiß dass er
vielleicht deutschland von dieser
geschlossene koalition gegen seinen
angriff gegenzug einbrechen kann wenn er
den deutschen dazu bringen kannst du
denken alles steht auf dem spiel und das
war sehr schlafen putin er hat
deutschland abhängig gemacht
aber der ist ein bisschen wie ein geist
meine deutschen in geiselhaft aber die
koalition ist noch nicht geschlossen
also die türkei
beteiligt sich an keinen sanktionen es
gibt auch betriebsverlagerungen typ der
türkei zum beispiel aus meiner heimat im
saarland ein traditionshersteller
porzellan geht in die türkei weil die
türkei hat zwei pipelines aus russland
lässt sich natürlich an
dieser koalition ist nicht geschlossen
und gerade diese schwäche provoziert
putin er denkt wir werden nicht ernst
ist gegen ihm ins feld bringen werden
sie vor allem nach deutschland noch mehr
macht absolut weil immerhin das ist eine
provokation ihren denn nein wir werden
natürlich man muss eine strategie haben
wo man weder den dritten weltkrieg noch
bankrott hat aber auf der anderen seite
kann man nicht sagen weil wir uns nicht
ruinieren wollen müssen wir alles zu
lassen was gut ihn macht nein denn wenn
er erfolg hat in der ukraine dann schaut
er auch auf dem baltikum denn wenn man
hört was putin sagt er will nicht mit
ukraine aufhören und ich sage wieder
würde deutschland stärke zeigen es würde
putin überraschend hier kalkuliert damit
dass deutschland immer auf die bremse
drückt statt auf den gasbedarf wenn es
um widerstand gegen seine pläne geht na
gut wenn man am tropf hängt ist es
schwierig stärke zu zeigen erzählt ich
denke manchmal dass frau wagenknecht
dann manchmal so ein bisschen die
kommunistische plattform doch wieder
durchschimmert
ich kann das nur als irgendwie so ein
bisschen zu den latenten freude daran
sehen dass der westen dann da stünde
wenn wir jetzt zu kreuze kriechen
müssten und 19 2 aufmachen und weil wir
ja wir haben es probiert wir haben
versucht abzuklemmen ja jetzt ist er
jetzt falls uns ein bisschen lassen was
wieder das schiff wieder wieder
betrunken wie das ist da wieder
verweichlichte begossene pudel der sich
zu viel vorgenommen hat mit seinem
sanktionen wenn man solche sanktionen
beschließt da kann man vorher darüber
nachdenken ob sie eine elf spuckt oder
möchte man und wenn man sie beschlossen
hat kann man nicht in der einige jahre
neben wenn es wenn man merkt
dass
andere länder macht nix da ja gut also
wie gesagt das andere problem ist doch
die deutsche öffentlichkeit sehen sich
ja immer danach möglichst nicht
militärisch zu agieren weil militär ist
immer böse und dann folgt die politik
dem opportunistisch wie sie ist und sagt
ja sanktionen also wir liefern zum
beispiel kein obst an apple a day keeps
putin werde sagte der frühere
agrarminister mal in seinem
unnachahmlichen englisch das ist alles
schwachsinn aber es folgt natürlich
einer stimmungslage die sachen können
wir ihn nicht mit friedlichen mitteln
umlenken muss man sich klar machen dass
man ein koloss wie russland nicht
einfach so
fordern sie dann also dass wir ein jahr
arbeit eingreifen ein aber man kann
jetzt nicht einfach wie sie daherkommen
und kann sagen jetzt zu apa das ist
jetzt noch alles ziemlich hart dann
macht man aus den zwei auf und nehmen
das billige gas und der sitzt dann in
seinem im kreml und sagt
ich brauche für sechs monate und schon
kommen die zu kreuze glaube die
tätlichkeit
aber das große problem ist doch die
energiewende die energiewende ist der
größte und massivste fehler der ära
merkel gewesen nicht nur von ihr
verschuldet sondern von allen
beteiligten erst aus atom auszusteigen
dann aus kohle auszusteigen und zu
glauben die rechnung geht auf und
stattdessen sich einseitig abhängig zu
machen von gas und jetzt hängen wir hier
am tropf